welcome to GameSpot gameplay where we
bring you the best games of the day so
you can make up your own mind up to this
point for night has had a fairly fun but
predictable loop of exploration resource
gathering base defense and tons of
backend chores for some players the base
defense sections are the best part and
they're getting a DLC that lets them
focus on just that survived the storm
pits players against waves of elemental
mutants for 14 harrowing nights
unfortunately that fun will come with a
lot more grinding due to the fact that
you'll need elemental guns because
certain elements are weak or strong
against certain mutants that also means
no more sticking with the same three
favorite weapons every match I have to
be honest I both liked the idea of a
survival based mode while not
particularly wanting more chores to do I
honestly enjoy fortnight and want to
know what you think about the new
survival mode alright let's get to it
good
shoot it stab it or fix that we got
trouble
[Applause]
sorry
courts take it on house
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
hey our fourth getting beat up
the night is almost over keep fighting
it's day let's repair and rebuild a
generator is ready to be upgraded we
need to upgrade the generator before
nightfall storm cogs incoming storm data
has been updated check your map
hey we just built that
by your enthusiasm Rene
you